minha amiga tomou iodo kelp e disse que
o nódulo da tireoide sumiu faz sentido
sim faz sentido já que o nódulo da
tireoide é um crescimento anormal pode
ser benigno ou em alguns casos mais
raros cancerígeno e O iodo kelp é uma
forma que eu gosto muito de reposição de
iodo que é um nutriente essencial pra
produção de hormônios da tireoide então
a deficiência deodo vai levar vários
problemas de tireoide incluindo o
desenvolvimento de nódulos então a ideia
de que o iodo kelp possa ajudar a
reduzir ou eliminar um nódulo na
tireóide é totalmente plausível
especialmente se o nódulo for causado
por deficiência desse mineral no entanto
é muito importante entender que o iodo
kelp ou qualquer outro suplemento não
deve ser usado como tratamento único
para nódulo da tireoide sem
acompanhamento médico e também muitas
vezes nutricional Então os nódulos de
tiroide tem várias causas um diagnóstico
preciso é muito importante então por
isso tem que ter acompanhamento médico
para poder determinar a melhor abordagem
e tratamento Além disso o uso de
suplementos de Udo tem que ser feito com
cautela geralmente tem que ser feito em
conjunto com o selênio pois o excesso de
iudo também pode causar problema se não
for contrabalançado pelo selênio então é
importante ter uma abordagem integrativa
considerando a Alimentação adequada
anlam ória um estilo de vida adequado
com hidratação musculação exercícios
aeróbicos né a suplementação orientada
por um bom profissional de saúde